we do start in court this was sentencing  day for a pet grooming shop owner  accused of animal cruelty today victor  garcia herrera received one year  probation for a gross misdemeanor charge  he owns paza's pet sitter mets up in the  northeast valley in january a report was  filed against the business saying a dog  died while in his care the business also  received previous complaints about  mistreated animals gina griesen of  nevada voters for animals spoke in court  today  we were involved in the beginning when  we were able to  file the complaint and turn over  i know  you know i appreciate everything that's  been done on this case  we don't think it's enough  garcia herrera denies still owning the  business the judge in the case noted she  doesn't have the authority to shut down  the business anyway as part of his  probation he will spend 11 days in jail  he also has to have no contact with  animals even his own